Olá meus amigos minhas amigas sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live do
grupo de
apoiadores boa noite Carlos à medida que
vocês forem entrando por favor vão dando
um alô uma boa noite e me dão por favor
também o feedback do áudio me digam se o
áudio está legal é muito importante a
gente checar o áudio em todas as
transmissões
para que seja certeza que a informação
tá chegando até vocês
eu vou começar a nossa transmissão com
alguns artigos interessantes que eu
separei aqui para conversar com vocês e
como já é de prática logo em seguida nós
vamos responder as dúvidas do documento
e as dúvidas também que vocês
apresentarem ao
vivo novamente Carlos se você tiver me
escutando por favor me dê um feedback do
áudio como é que tá o áudio e demais
participantes que ainda não se
manifestaram porque nós temos um bug
aqui no
streamar de que quando é uma live
fechada eu não tenho a informação de
quantas pessoas estão ao vivo então ess
é um bug do streamyard eu só ten essa
informação quando a gente tem uma live
aberta bem eu queria discutir um
pouquinho com vocês sobre medicamentos
de disfunção erétil e que poderiam
afetar o risco da doença de alzheimer
Boa noite Fernando castelani Obrigado
pela
informação o áudio tá ok muito bom
Denise boa noite obrigado pela
informação
também então aparentemente s tá ok então
homens com disfunção eré recém
diagnosticada e que foram prescritos com
os inibidores da 5 Alfa de esteras o
ipde5 como é o caso do cafil
tadalafila apresentaram segundo um
estudo 18% menos chances de desenvolver
a doença de alzheimer após 5 anos de
uso Esse estudo reforça a associação que
existe entre inibidores da cinco fossos
de esterase o tipo cinco e o risco de
Alzheimer porém teve um outro estudo que
não encontrou conexão que não encontrou
esse efeito protetor desses medicamentos
para prevenir a doença então devemos ter
cautela na interpretação dos
resultados especialistas não ligados a
nenhum dos dois estudos externos
enfatizam que não há evidências né ainda
solidificadas que Esses medicamentos da
classe do viagra do seales possam tratar
alheimer
recomendo cautela na interpretação dos
dados porém eu particularmente acho Pela
Minha experiência e também por outros
estudos que avaliam o uso desses
medicamentos para melhorar o fluxo
arterial de modo geral no organismo que
é bem provável que sim que Esses
medicamentos possam ter algum papel na
melhora do fluxo sanguíneo cerebral e
Inclusive eu utilizo umas fórmulas que
eu cologo doses bastas da lafila que
geralmente não dão efeitos colaterais
não dão dor muscular dor corporal ou
lombar que são efeitos bem comuns no
caso da to
lafila Então eu acho que isso aqui no
futuro vai ter realmente eh repercussões
desdobramentos
interessantes Então os pesquisadores
acreditam que os resultados apontam para
a necessidade de futuros estudos sobre a
eh mudança
de finalidade né Você pode colocar mais
objetivos na bula da medicação né isso
em inglês tem um termo chamado repurpose
né que é mudar o propósito né Eh rever o
propósito não sei se a tradução em
português seria correta
o uma tentativa de traduzir o temo
repurpose então Eh futuros estudos
precisam ser feitos pra gente ver se
realmente Esses medicamentos vão ser
realmente eficazes para prevenir
Alzheimer tô falando mais sobre o estudo
que foi um estudo realizado no Reino
Unido incluiu muita gente foram 270.000
pessoas com a idade média de 59 anos 55%
deles tinham prescrições para usar
remédios para ereção
eh então seguindo uma média de 5,1 anos
de uso dessas medicações então
praticamente metade desse pessoal do
Estudo estava usando um pouquinho mais
da metade estava usando há mais de 5
anos então a redução do risco de
Alzheimer foi mais forte em pessoas com
mais de 70 anos de idade ou com
histórico de hipertensão arterial
diabetes e naqueles com maior número de
prescrições
desses medicamentos para hipertensão ou
para
diabetes Então pode ter alguns fatores
que não foram aí levados em consideração
que podem ter atrapalhado A análise de
dados por exemplo atividade física
desses participantes e também atividade
sexual isso não foi rastreado no estudo
e pode influenciar nos resultados Então
precisamos obviamente de ensaios
clínicos
randomizados para ter certeza
disso esses ensaios TM que ser bem
desenhados
também porém destaca seu potencial
desses resultados para abrir novas vias
para o novo uso de medicamentos já
estabelecidos já
aprovados com os estudos adicionais
focados na diversidade de pessoas
vivendo com a doença e o Fernando já tem
uma perguntinha aqui uso trad lafila em
pequenas doses e continuamente aumenta o
óxido nítrico sim porque ele uma enzima
que degrada o óxido nítrico Ok pode
ajudar com zumbido no ouvido
nunca usei para essa finalidade Fernando
mas eh eu tenho uma receita para zumbido
que é uma receita que aumenta fluxo
sanguíneo Eu nunca coloquei T la fila
nessa composição específica mas eu
imagino que sim que poderia ajudar né eu
vou até dar uma pesquisada rápida depois
se existe algum estudo de tal fila para
zumbido eu não conheço pelo fato de não
conhecer não quer dizer que não exista
né Pode ser que exista
sim
bem o próximo artigo que eu queria
discutir com vocês é sobre um debate
fascinante que foi publicado na
conceituada revista americana médica
hypertension São dois editoriais que
apresentam argumentos contundentes sobre
uma questão de saúde que é bastante
discutida se deveríamos ou não focar
mais em restringir o sal o sódio ou
aumentar a ingestão de potássio para
reduzir a
arterial então a respostaa pergunta se
aprofunda numa complexa fisiologia renal
um tema que intriga bastante
nefrologistas mas também depende
variáveis como o contexto geográfico e
seu objetivo é tratar indivíduos
específicos ou ainda desenvolver
políticas alimentares eficazes eu sou do
time que acredita que é muito mais
importante do que restringir o sal de
cozinha é você aumentar o potássio e o
magnésio e existem pessoas geneticamente
favoráveis a usar o sal que nunca vão
ter pressão alta com uso de sal de
cozinha e tem pessoas que T genética que
tornam elas vulneráveis que o sódio vai
aumentar a pressão arterial então isso
não é feito ainda em larga escala Esses
exames genéticos mas seriam úteis paraa
gente poder definir Quem deveria ou não
fazer restrição de
sódio o Fernando tá perguntando a
receita do zumbido seria ginobili ftina
Sim esses dois compostos aí gin loba e
vimpocetina são alguns desses compostos
que a gente utiliza nessa receita sim
Fernando a Estela tá dando boa noite boa
noite Estela bem vamos continuar aqui
então temos os o time que defende a
restrição de sódio e o time que defende
a reposição de potássio vamos falar
primeiro do time em defesa da restrição
de sódio então segundo o autor stepen
jur cheque que é o médico PH
que trabalha no Hospital Beth Israel e
aqui em Boston ele é coautor de um dos
editoriais que é a favor da restrição de
sódio ele diz que esse argumento da
restrição do sódio é robusto e
substancialmente apoiado por um vasto
número de estudos então ele destaca a
intervenção famosa chamada
intersal também a dieta conhecida nos
Estados Unidos como dieta Dash
D que é uma dieta específica para
hipertensão arterial que tem restrição
de sódio eu estudo to HP que demonstram
uma relação consistente linear entre a
redução do sódio e a diminuição da
pressão arterial no entanto ele
reconhece que o estudo do pir que é um
outro estudo levantou questionamentos ao
sugerir que uma restrição extrema de
sódio aíe tá falando uma restrição muito
alta de sódio poderia paradoxalmente
elevar a mortalidade Car vascular Então
esse estudo contudo Esse estudo que
falou da restrição muito alta de sódio
estudo pu ele sofreu muitas críticas
metodológicas incluindo a forma de
medição de sódio através de uma única
amostra de urina a polêmica sobre a
restrição de sódio gerou intensas
discussões no meio científico com
diferentes laudos desculpa diferentes
lados se formando nas chamadas guerras
do Sal
então em busca de uma
resolução um grupo de pesquisadores
propôs realizar um estudo randomizado em
prisões Americanas mas essa ideia nunca
se materializou devido às questões
éticas né Politicamente correto e a
revelações sobre financiamento não
divulgado pela indústria do sal que a
indústria do Sal tá até se metendo nisso
aqui então estudos mais recentes como o
SSA e o carid ssbp
fornece dados promissores indicando que
reduzir o sódio da dieta pode ser tão
eficaz quanto medicamento para baixar a
pressão arterial bem isso porque eles
sempre se baseiam no sal marinho
refinado né o sal refinado eles nunca
usam o sal integral como base de
comparação bem vamos ao segundo grupo né
que é o grupo da suplementação de
potássio Boa noite Adriana Boa noite
Cristina então um gruto grupo
que é capitaneado pelo swapnil
hema que também é médico que tem um
mestrado e é da Universidade de otau no
Canadá Ele defende no editorial a
importância da suplementação de potássio
apontando para estudos menores que são
significativos que revelam o potencial
dessa reposição de potássio na redução
da pressão arterial então o estudo da
dieta das por exemplo incentivou um
aumento na ingestão de potássio através
de frutas e vegetais e o estudo
ssas testou um substituto do sal
contendo 25% de potássio Então eu tenho
recomendado para alguns pacientes um sal
de carpen que é um sal de um
pesquisador lá da dos países nórdicos eu
acho que ele é da Finlândia o carpen da
Finlândia
desenvolveu uma
fórmula que substitui o sal de cozinha
que é rico em potá e
magnésio Então esse autor que defende o
potássio RF reconhece a complexidade na
a complexidade na relação entre a
redução de sódio e suplementação de
potássio sugerindo que a sinergia entre
as duas abordagens pode ser a chave para
uma intervenção eficaz então ele diz de
você tentar executar as duas coisas em
conjunto né Vamos algumas considerações
práticas e desafi doos sabores então a
questão prática de como aumentar a
ingestão de potássio e diminuir o sódio
gera debates né recomendar dietas mais
saudáveis é Bem óbvio mas encontra
vários obstáculos na vida real de falta
de
aderência custos e brigar com hábitos
alimentares já muito bem estabelecidos
né então por outro lado suplementos de
potássio podem enfrentar a resistência
devido a preocupações que muitos têm com
o excesso de potássio que é hipercalemia
questões também de gosto de Paladar que
não fica tão agradável porque pessoas aí
relatam gosto
metálico então alternativas de sal com
substituição de sódio com potássio podem
ser uma solução tem esse desafio de
ajustar os níveis para que o sabor seja
aceitável E além disso a eficácia da
substituição de sal é questionável em
países como os Estados Unidos onde a
maior parte do sódio vem de alimentos
processados e não vem do sal de cozinha
adicionado durante o cozimento ou
durante o momento que se serve a mesa
então lá nos Estados Unidos e outros
países aí que ditos desenvolvidos tem
muito alimento processado né isso
atrapalha porque até numa coca-cola no
refrigerante tem bastante
sódio Boa noite a todos que estão
entrando Então apesar da divergência
desses dois editoriais que eu acabei de
mencionar o o a turma do Tiro sal né
tiro sódio que é o a turma do jur cheque
e a turma do coloca potá do hir maaf
eles concordam em alguns pontos nesses
pontos que eles concordam é que eles de
uma maneira de outros dois ainda
reconhecem a importância de restringir o
sódio né pelo menos o sódio
processado existe uma recente proposta
de mudança de regra pela fda americana
nos Estados Unidos que permitiria que
substitutos do sal fossem rotulados como
sal isso é visto como um passo na
direção certa mas ambos os grupos
concordam que ainda muito trabalho a ser
feito Christopher labos que é um
cardiologista com especialização em
epidemiologia ressalta a importância de
permanecer crítico e aberto as mudanças
na ciência médica ele que é um
contribuinte regular para publicações e
programas de saúde ele reitera que
devemos visar abordagens práticas
exequíveis na luta contra a pressão
arterial alta adaptando as estratégias
realidades locais individuais quer dizer
Nesse artigo que eu tô falando para
vocês que foi extraído do medscape não
se fala em
magnésio isso me surpreendeu um pouco né
ninguém falou do papel do magnésio na
pressão
arterial
bem Tem mais um artigo aqui depois nós
partimos para as perguntas
Então esse artigo que eu queria discutir
com vocês o terceiro artigo do dia é
sobre a metiformina né o princípio ativo
do glifage ele foi aprovado pelo fda em
94 como a escolha Inicial primeiro
tratamento para o diabetes tipo 2 é um
medicamento muito antigo mas só foi em
94 que ele foi colocado como primeira
opção para o tratamento diabetes tipo do
por quê Porque ele é barato tem uma
eficácia interessante um baixo risco de
hipoglicemia ele não afeta a princípio
muito peso tem um histórico de segurança
e Como já disse de acessibilidade então
só que apareceram novos medicamentos aí
nos últimos anos com benefícios
cardiovasculares nos estudos e também
benefícios nos rins de preservação de
função renal e está se questionando se a
metiformina deveria continuar sendo a
terapia inicial para todos os pacientes
que têm diabetes tipo
do Então existe essa tendência atual
Entre várias especialidades médicas de
dar mais valor mais prioridade a
proteção dos órgãos e a redução do Risco
cardiometabólico e eles estão revendo
Então por causa de uns estudos que
saíram em relação os agonistas de
receptor glp1 que é a turma lá que do em
pique e também do do saxenda né são os
agonistas do receptor glp1 e os
inibidores do
sglt2 que são aqueles remédios que dão
a liberação de açúcar na urina como é o
caso do forxiga Então essas duas classes
de remédios segundo os estudos que
saíram os últimos 5 anos reduzem eventos
cardiovasculares adversos
maiores independentemente de usar ou não
junto a metiformina então três estudos
importantes sobre inibidores de
sglt2 novamente o grupo do forxiga
confirma benefício secundários renais
reduzindo a progressão da doença renal
hospitalizações por insuficiência
cardíaca e morte cardiovascular então a
associação americana de diabetes passou
a dar orientações a partir do ano
passado e também o Consenso da aace que
é uma outra associa
passaram a recomendar os agonistas do
receptor glp1 como eu falei é o caso do
saxenda e do e do em pique inibidores de
sglt2 a turma do forxiga para pacientes
com diabetes tipo 2 com ou em alto risco
de doença cardiovascular com
aterosclerose associada ou mesmo
sistência cardíaca ou doença renal
crônica
independentemente da necessidade de
controle glicémico ional né então a
associação americana de diabetes agora
considera os inibidores de
sglt2 como terapia padrão em pacientes
que tenham diabetes 2 e doença renal
crônica com uma taxa de filtração
glomerular aí pouco acima de 20 m por
minuto que seria uma sência renal
moderada já entrando pro
Severo então eles enfatizam que a
seleção da terapia inicial para
pacientes com com diabetes tipo do deve
ser
individualizado levando em consideração
metodos de tratamento preferência e
acesso aos medicamentos e ainda
reconhece a importância que a
metiformina ainda tem para pacientes que
T diabetes tipo do e não tem doença
cardíaca ou renal
significativa mas novamente reforçam que
os agonistas de glp1 inibidores da sglt2
podem ser considerados como tratamento
de primeira linha para aquele que tem
doença renal ou doença
cardíaca muito bem vamos para as
perguntas agora tenho tinha mais um
artigo aqui mas eu vou deixar paraa
semana que
vem deixa eu abrir aqui o
documento Temos 22 perguntas
hoje deixa eu dividir a tela aqui com
vocês
aqui vou deixar somente as perguntas na
tela para ficar mais fácil leitura
pergunta do Carlos
kman Pera aí que eu tô ampliando a
página
errada
aí agina é contraindicada para quem tem
diabetes ou pré-diabetes Que eu saiba
não
Carlos Que eu saiba não você viu isso em
algum lugar se você tiver Aliás você
está ao vivo né eu vi que você está ao
vivo se você puder me dizer se você viu
em algum lugar essa
informação porque Até onde eu sei ela
não é contraindicada
não então tem algumas evidências que a
arginina poderia baixar a pressão
arterial e dependendo
da combinação de remédios poderia até
baixar demais a pressão arterial Mas
isso não é uma contraindicação aí é
melhor você fazer o quê usar arginina
que é muito mais saudável Muito mais
natural e baixar a dose dos remédios
para
diabetes e essa faz muito mais sentido
na minha cabeça do que suspender a
agelina
porque a arginina vai ter efeitos muito
benéficos no diabetes ele vai aumentar a
sensibilidade insulina reduzir a
progressão
pro uma forma mais grave de diabet tipo
do então tem estudos falando que o
tratamento com agelina poderia reduzir o
risco ou retardar o desenvolvimento do
diabet tipo
do então tem benefícios aqui no caso se
o paciente tá tomando muito remédio para
diabetes é muito mais interessante ele
suspender um desses remédios ou baixar a
dos do que parar
arginina Faria muito mais
sentido se você tiver mais alguma
observação para fazer ao
vivo estou à sua disposição ok Porque eu
sei que você está acompanhando a Live
vamos paraa próxima
pergunta
Cadê essa tinta
aqui com relação D mso tenho duas
perguntas na faculdade veterinária
diziam para usar luvas pois era
cancerígeno quando eu manipulava sem
luva senti o gosto na boca
imediatamente cancerígeno não é a não
ser que nessa concentração que vocês
trabalhavam poderia ser muito
alta
ok é exatamente como você colocou aqui
talvez seria pelo uso contínuo de
concentração alta eu não li nada a
respeito que poderia ser cancerígeno mas
eu vou checar isso
agora mas na literatura que eu li não vi
essa
informação
que poderia ser cancerígeno em doses
mais elevadas mas é é capaz de ser uma
coisa real isso daí porque pode ser uma
coisa muito
concentrada sim é verdade sim eh ao
longo dos anos houve uma preocupação com
Ah o demencial em altas concentrações
que poderiam ser
cancerígenos Então essa informação que
você tá passando ela
é verídica
Ok o dmso eh não é listado por si só
como cancin gênico ou seja como uma
substância que vai gerar câncer por
agências regulatórias dos Estados Unidos
importantes
porém houve essa preocupação de que em
altas doses ele podia gerar efeito
carcinogênico
tá então a maioria das fontes que eu tô
checando aqui agora tá dizendo que não
tem evidências muito sólidas que ele
seja sim cancerígeno mas essa história
de ser cancerígeno em altas doses foi
levantada ao longo dos
anos porém mesmo não sendo classificado
como carcinogênico pelas principais
agências o dmso ele pode causar
irritação na pele problemas
respiratórios
pode ter também efeitos adversos no
trato
reprodutivo e só foi realmente
confirmado esse efeito cancerígeno em
dados animais com concentrações muito
altas
Ok vamos paraa próxima
pergunta com relação a essa moda atual
de submerso em gelo Qual a sua opinião
você concorda saberia de alguma fonte
então isso tem evidência desculpa que eu
tô com a garganta ainda meio chata
ultimamente tem evidência assim de que
mas não é bem só o gelo é você fazer
choque térmico você alternar entre calor
e gelo você vai ativar umas proteínas
especiais chamado chaperonas ou Hit
Shock proteins tá então quando você
ativa essas
proteínas você tá causando O quê você tá
causando a o aumento das vias que
promovem a longevidade Então essa
história de ficar alternando entre calor
e gelo sauna e e entrar no gelo sim tem
evidências muita gente faz o próprio
pesquisador do
envelhecimento um dos principais aí ele
faz isso com frequência ele faz sauna e
alterna com gelo e me fugiu o nome dele
agora mas eu tenho um vídeo no canal que
fala disso tá já tem Acho que uns dois
anos que eu fiz esse vídeo é do David
Sinclair me lembrei o nome dele agora o
David Sinclair que faz isso ele alterna
entre gelo e
calor por causa dessa ativação das
chaperonas ru Elita o doutor
recomendaria um bom profissional para
tratar câncer de mama
agressivo de cabeça aqui o
Doutor José de Felipe Júnior em São
Paulo e também o Dr
Gustavo
cara me fugiu o nome do fugiu sobrenome
dele vou olhar aqui Dr
Gustavo Vilela tá Dr Gustavo Vilela e Dr
José de Felipe Júnior são os dois
profissionais que me vem de cabeça aqui
tem outros oncologistas integrativos tá
tem
outros mas esse tem a Dra Ana Lua
bacarim também é outra oncologista
integrativa vamos próxima
pergunta para uma pessoa de 70 anos com
osteoporose apesar da suplementação
indicada por anos a medicação pretal
seria a melhor recomendação
Então isso é muito discutível eh rolita
o que eu recomendo a você é que antes de
tentar comia ou os bifosfonatos
você tentaria fazer uso tá de vitamina
D3
K2 magnésio cobre zinco e também boro
fósforo
msm vitamina A também ajuda vitamina E
também ajuda especialmente a os
tocotrienóis o caso aí do tirados do
Urucum né os tocotrienóis são muito bons
para saúde oss então tentar um
tratamento desse junto com a musculação
aí uma segunda linha de tratamento se
esse primeiro não for bem sucedido aliás
aumento também do colágeno das proteínas
ingeridas especialmente o colágeno a
segunda linha seria o uso de se semanas
aí
de de um anabol an que aumenta a massa
óssea que eu sei que muita gente tem eh
preconceito pela toda a propaganda
negativa que foi feita com anabolizantes
eh mas eu acredito que por seis semanas
eu nunca vi dar problema é só você usar
por pouco tempo com uma dose baixo e aí
como terceira opção eu usaria o prolia
porque o prolia mais problemático do que
anabolizante tem mais efeito
colateral vamos pra próxima
pergunta aqui Walter sobre uso de dhe
tem efeitos colaterais tem Walter
especialmente em mulheres se mulher usar
a dose alta vai ter virilização porque o
Deia em mulher é muito convertido em
testosterona se a dose ficar alta demais
ela vai ter pelos corporais aumentados
acne oleosidade da pele pode ter
alteração da voz pode ter hipertrofia
clitoriana pode aumentar pressão
arterial
pode ficar obesa pode ficar com edema né
com inchaço então tem uma série de
recomendações Tom muito cuidado com a
dose homem é difícil dar esse problema
homem tem uma tolerância muito alta a
udia porque não vira tanto testosterona
e também homem já tem uma tendência a
testosterona alta né bem mais alta que
mulher pode se usar por tempo
indeterminado contando que você use as
doses corretas então para homem por
volta de 20 MG por dia paraa
mulher por volta de 10 mg por dia homem
pode usar até 50 mg 100 mg tem alguns
estudos usando Deia em doença autoimune
com alguns bons resultados Mas aí você
encara todos os efeitos colaterais da
dose alta que são digamos assim menos
ruim do que o efeito da doença
autoimune deixa eu alternar aqui paraas
perguntas ao
vivo
uma pergunta boa aqui do Fernando esses
estudos recomendando Esses medicamentos
mais novos não estariam sendo
tendenciosos visto que a formina já
perdeu patente sim Fernando eu tenho
essa chance de ser eh tendencioso sim
como são vários estudos a chance de
tendência de ser tendencioso É menor né
mas você tem razão essa sua colocação é
bem válida
aqui eu provalmente sou muito mais a
favor da metiformina do que desses
outros que eu falei mas eu tava só
passando o estudo para vocês não quer
dizer que necessariamente eu concordo
100% com o estudo Fernando casteliano a
liberação de açúcar na urina não
prejudica mais os
zins nesse caso segundo esses estudos
não o que o que prejudicaria seria
aumentar muito o risco de infecção
urinária que eu vejo muito na prática
essas pessoas terem infecção urinária de
repetição especialmente mulher
Fernanda O Senhor trabalha com reposição
hormonal geralmente a partir de que
idade mulher já deve começar depende
Fernanda tem mulheres que com 35 tem
outras com 45 e outras com 55 é muito
variável vai depender muito de mulher
para mulher mas você pode sim fazer a
modulação hormonal que que a dose é mais
baixa antes de fazer reposo hormonal em
Mulheres que ainda estão menstruando que
tem sintomas aí que justificaria você
fazer Essa modulação especialmente
irritabilidade alterações de sono baixa
de libido ressecamento vaginal e
cansaço
eh Carlos Elina vi numa recomendação da
internet mas só em o local pergunto
porque estranhei então Ó Carlos eu
expliquei já né a alenina ela vai baixar
o açúcar do sangue Então faz muito mais
sentido você baixar o remédio do que
suspender a arginina né Eu acho você já
entendeu Mas se você tiver mais alguma
observação tô à disposição Fernando em
relação à função renal o doutor
recomenda algum suplemento paraa melhora
da mesma tem vários tá o principal deles
é com enzima que 10 em altas doses
também el carnitina ajuda muito taurina
ajuda bastante também esses são os três
que eu também tem a o caso do ácido Alf
lipoico então esses e o nac então esses
todos aí vão ajudar na função renal
ã o que que significa relação entre cd8
e CD4 é relação entre os linfócitos
citotóxicos os Killers né com os que são
os helpers né os
auxiliares Esse é é um exame muito
utilizado para quem tem HIV ou para quem
tem alguma suspeita de
imunossupressão então a relação entre os
dois dois vai dizer se a pessoa tá tendo
algum tipo de
imunossupressão dos sistema de defesa
imunitária celular para isso que serve
esse exame bem vamos continuar aqui com
os outros perguntas do
documento para o caso de uso de ivet
Anita aí que a gente pode falar é Não
não pode tá no YouTube Eh tava o fato de
ter grupo fechado não quer dizer que o
YouTube não tá monitorando então para o
caso de uso de Ivete Anita para
tratamento complimentar da dengue quais
seriam as doses e
posologias
as mesmas que foram utilizados durante
aquele evento de saúde que você sabe
qual que é né mesmas doses tá Eu
recomendo usar durante 5 dias o a ivet
seria um comprimido para cada 30 kg de
peso um comprimento cada 30 kg de peso
então se você tem 60 kg são do se você
tem 90 kg são TR se você tiver entre 60
e 90 continua sendo TRS você toma uma
vez ao dia junto com uma ção geralmente
éo jantar por 5 dias o Anita é a dose
padrão do Anita que eu não tô agora me
lembrando de cabeça mas eu posso olhar
aqui eu não uso tanto Anita Não tá eu eu
sei dos estudos e tudo mas geralmente eu
prefiro usar a ivermectina mas eu várias
vezes Anita também só que eu não fiquei
com a dose na cabeça mas eu vou checar
isso para você
agora Me dá só mho
Acho que vai demorar um pouquinho mais
do que eu imaginei aqui me dá só um
instante
chando meus minhas anotações de
prontuário
aqui aqui era uma dose de 500 mg de 88
horas tá 500 mg de 88 horas no caso do
do Anita Ok essa a mesma dose aí que foi
utilizado durante a o evento de saúde
que você sabe qual que é
tô no caso tratamento complementar da
dengue utilizando
montelucaste qual seria a dose e a
posologia isso não tá no vídeo que eu
publiquei eu acho que tá lá
e dá uma olhada no no vídeo mas tem
muita gente que publicou isso no
Instagram Pera aí que eu vou achar a
dose para você
não é um remédio também que eu tenho
muita prática não eu não usei o Montel
cast durante a o evento de saúde tá de
do anos
atrás mas já tinha também gente falando
sobre o uso do mon
lucast tá são 10 mg por dia por 10
dias tá seria essa dose do Montel cast
vamos continuar aqui eu não tenho
certeza se eu falei isso no vídeo eu não
falei acho que
não é interessante ter um gerador de
hidrogênio molecular em casa eu acho que
é sim Francisco eu tô conversando com
duas empresas que quando eu fiz a Live
eu não tinha muito conhecimento de
geradores brasileiros mas mas tem duas
empresas já trabalhando com hidrogênio
molecular eh no Brasil qual que é a
vantagem dele sobre as
[Música]
garrafas então a garrafa por si só é o
mini gerador de
hidrogênio ou você compraria um gerador
de hidrogênio maior caso você queira
trabalhar com o hidrogênio inalado em
casa além do hidrogênio ingerido seria
essa a
diferença quais os requisitos para saber
se o produto é bom você pedir para eles
os testes de de de qualidade pra empresa
te passar eh os laudos de que eles têm
de certificação dos produtos seria essa
o
critério não pelo marketing não vai pelo
marketing vai e pede pro pessoal o
documento tem diferença semente sucupira
branca para graúda serve fazer garrafada
ou chá qual líquido mais apropriado para
fazer garrafada dessa semente eh eu vou
ficar te devendo essa resposta Eliana
porque eu não estudei su Cupira a ponto
de est te respondendo isso viu mas isso
é um bom assunto para um vídeo eu acho
que Sucupira não vai ter tanta
informação online viu
a não são informações assim leigas viu
mas eu vou dar uma olhada nesse assunto
depois você me cobra por favor Eliana
para não esquecer disso pode cobrar no
grupo
quando uma pessoa tem uma retenção
urinária várias horas sem urinar o que
deve fazer deve ir para hospital para
fazer
a a sondagem né nem que seja uma
sondagem de alívio pode ser que tenha
que colocar uma sonda de alívio ou uma
sonda de demora eh tem que ir para
emergência para tratar sim ou tem alguma
outra coisa que a gente possa fazer em
casa não a não ser que você tenha uma
sonda em casa e você tenha treinamento
de como passar uma sonda né não é o caso
de 99,9 % das pessoas então se você não
sabe passar sonda e não tem sonda em
casa não tem o que fazer vai ter que ir
para hospital agora se você sabe passar
sonda E por acaso conhece Onde comprar
uma cirúrgica uma hospitalar que você
possa fazer a compra e aí você poderia
se arriscar a fazer essa sondagem em
casa se você tiver o treinamento Por
quanto tempo a pessoa pode ficar sem
urinar eu não recomendo que fique por
mais de 6 horas tá que já pode começar a
danificar o rim
eh nem que seja uma um dano que seja
transitório mas mais de 6 horas já é
complicado
tá Quais são os cuidados de uma pessoa
idosa ao ter infecção
urinária tratar essa infecção urinária
da melhor forma possível e deixar essa
pessoa bem hidratada
eh são os cuidados
principais ela pode tomar antibiótico
sim pode deve dependendo do grau de
infecção é difícil você passar por cima
do antibiótico Luciano não devemos
né tornar o antibiótico inimigo né o
antibiótico ele só é usado em excessivo
né no Brasil mas não quer dizer que o
antibiótico não tem indicação tem
indicação sim só que você tem que ter
critério a utilizar o antibiótico o que
eu recomenda que depois do uso desse
antibiótico sejam implementadas as
medidas para evitar que a infecção volte
se for um homem prostático por exemplo
desobstruir esse homem seja com remédio
ou seja com cirurgia se for uma mulher
que tem por exemplo prolapso genital tem
que tratar o prolapso genital se for
alguém com cálculo urinário tratar o
cálculo urinário Então tem que tratar a
origem dessa infecção urinária de
repetição e usar o antibiótico o mínimo
possível por conta das resistências
bacterianas dos efeitos colaterais mas
muitas vezes não tem jeito de não usar
antibiótico
pode falar um pouco sobre a naringenina
naringenina é um flavonoide muito
interessante tem efeito
antioxidante e ele é um agente bem
interessante aí que tem efeito parecido
com
atina certo deixa
eu passar mais informações para vocês
porque ess também não é um ativo que eu
uso muito
não
então eh ele é retirado principalmente
das frutas cítricas da Bergamota também
pode ser extraído de
tomate ele tem várias atividades
biológicas ele tem ação antioxidante
antitumoral antiviral antibacteriana
antiinflamatória anti
adipogênese
protetores tem poucos estudos clínicos é
mais estudo em vitro ou em vivo então
precisa de mais estudos em
pessoas e tem alguns problemas porque
ele tem uma farmacocinética difícil né
acho que ele é pouco
absorvido houve um estudo Clínico que
investigou a segurança a farmacocinética
na na áa in Genina em pessoas adultas
saudáveis em doses que variaram De 150 a
900 MG por dia e ele foi considerado
seguro nessas doses
no hve efeitos colaterais
importantes tá e tem sido utilizado para
proteção para evitar doenças
cardiovasculares ele tem apresentado uma
redução na peroxid ação lipídica ele
ajuda a evitar esse efeito aí de
oxidativo tem efeitos também
antiaterogênica e
antiinflamatório Evita o acúmulo de
gordura no
fígado ou seja ele previne o fígado
gorduroso né
esteatose então ele é um ativo bastante
promissor
e que tá sendo estudado mas ele é não é
um ativo ainda que é
usado muito assim
muita muito abertamente digamos assim
com muita quantidade
de
inclusive vou dar uma chocada aqui se
tem fornecedores na manipulação de
Narinha Genina eu tenho a impressão que
sim sim tem sim tem a Vena farmacêutica
ele é um ativo da Active
cudic então ele é possível S ser
manipulado Apesar de eu não usar muito
ele ele ele pode ser
manipulado nas manipulações nasas
magistrais bem vamos pra próxima
aqui Eliseu lá de quinta-feira a Live da
quinta-feira agora vai ser com a d
eliser é uma dermatologista tricologista
integrativa tricologia significa ciência
do cabelo então ela é uma dermatologista
mais focada em cabelo mas também trata a
saúde geral através da avaliação do
cabelo então vai ser essa Live que nós
vamos
fazer vi num vídeo seu feito há quatro
semanas sobre a relação entre gordura no
fígado e
frutas foi dito que frutas perigosas
para o fígado caso consumidas
diariamente caqui manga abacaxxi todas
as frutas doces né banana uva passa
damasco e melancia frutas cujo suco pode
ser tomado diariamente que não faz mal
açaí cereja as vermelhas abacate
maracujá deve ser e polpa né do Coco
limão toranja maracujá sim beber suco de
acerola todo dia produz gordura no
fígado não porque a acerola é uma fruta
que não tem alto terro de Açúcar A não
ser que você Ione o açúcar comer mamão
todo dia produz gordura no fígado
geralmente não mamão tem a fibra que
segura absorção do açúcar
Tá qual a diferença entre esses dois
suplementos Alfa lipóico R ácido Alfa
lipóico é que a absorção do R ácido Alfa
lipóico é maior essa que é a diferença
tá é uma questão de absorção que seria
maior com esse que tem aí a o prefixo
R quando perguntei na última live comç
com ovos crus uma hora depois do almoço
a intenção não era absorver melhor a
proteína a intenção eraa confirmar seria
fazer mal prejudicar a digestão comer
cinco ovos crus com almos não não quia
que vai prejudicar a digestão
não não vai não o que pode acontecer
você corre um risco de ficar intoxicado
por salmonela né Por xiga porque o tá
cru se você tiver certeza absoluta que
esse ovo não tá
deteriorado não haveria problema mas ex
esse risco de intoxicação alimentar pro
tacuru só
isso na última Live perguntei se faz mal
ingerir 5 mg de B12 é uma dose alta tá
eh mas não para tomar todo dia né Por
injeção
tranquilo esqueci de mencionar aqui a
minha pergunta daum 5 mg de B12 viia
suplemento todo dia não a dose é alta
demais não há necessidade dessa dessa
dose tão alta viu a não ser em situações
muito específicas Eliseu porque aí você
vai ficar urinando essa B12 você não vai
utilizar essa B12 toda no
organismo 1 MG de B12 já tem excesso
geralmente de B12 então 5 mg é a dose
muito alta para tomar todo
dia geralmente não vai fazer mal mas
você vai tá jogando dinheiro
fora assisti um vídeo seu onde falava da
planta quebra pedra para eliminar
cálculo renal sim existe outra boa na
sua
opinião quem está com cálculo renal pode
fazer uso de vitamina C Depende a
vitamina C ela Possi só em excesso
Teoricamente poderia provocar cálculo
renal Por acidificar demais a urina na
prática não vejo acontecer isso mas isso
tá relatado na literatura então de um
modo geral se o seu cálculo renal
por exemplo de ácido úrico a vitamina C
já não seria
indicada porque poderia piorar o ácido
úrico por acidificar urina aí vai
cristalizar mais ainda os cristais de
ácido
úrico tem outras plantas sim viu o
Denise que vão ajudar no cálculo renal
fora o quebra-pedra mas a maioria dessas
plantas não tem no Brasil mas eu já vi
isso em artigos
científicos
irci O Quarteto Sinatra tem
contraindicação para quem tem apenas
ruim não não tem contraindicação tá
liberado
sim aquele vídeo sobre dengue você disse
que própolis Verde B2 ajuda na formação
das plaquetas em caso de
dengue Isso significa que eu consumir
própolis Verde B2 para recelar as pretas
suplemento estrato de folh de mão
torna-se dispensável pode se tornar
dispensável Sim mas você pode associar
vai depender muito da da da questão de
quanto que essas plaquetas estão baixas
né no vídeo sobre as grandes mentiras
alimentares você diz que os Sis Marin
integral Celta e rosa him Malá são menos
refinados isso significa que o sal rosa
de Himalaia que eu consumo da marca
Smart refinado não eh eles geralmente
não são refinados
né mas você tem que ver com o fornecedor
do do do sal e com o
fabricante bem vamos ver aqui
as perguntas ao vivo que sobraram
aqui o Fernand uso seria de apenas Ivete
e Anita ou usa apenas uma das duas eu
usaria só uma das duas não usaria as
duas juntas não
tá
legal Carlos Obrigado pelo depoimento aí
do uso do hidrogênio
molecular ao usar o trimetilglicina para
baixar aína quando usar junto ao na para
melhora renal tenho que aumentar a dosei
glicina para manter o efeito de baixa
arna tanto na quanto trimi glicina baixa
aína talvez você não sabia que o na
também baixa aa mais baixa tá
eh
é você pode usar uma dose semelhante dos
dois você pode usar por exemplo 500 mg
de nac com 500 mg do trimi glicina duas
vezes ao
dia sim a beberina ela pode piorar
piorar não aumentar o efeito dos
Remédios
anticoagulantes Sim pode ser usado com
ômega3 contanto que você não use dose
alta dos
dois
então Eliseu essa história de não tomar
nada para febre é muito bonito na teoria
mas na
prática sabe eu duvido você impedir uma
mãe de baixar a febre da criança el eles
não vão escutar essa história essa
história é muito teoria e pouca prática
duvido eu não consegui todos os meus
filhos Meus dois filhos quando tiveram
febre eu não consegui convencer a mãe
deles a não dar antitérmico então na
prática eu acho que esse negócio não
funciona se vocês conhecem alguma mãe
que teve o sangue frio de não D
antitérmico vocês me avisam porque eu
nunca vi isso na
prática Eu não sei você tá querendo
dizer com essa história de líquido e
sólido não eh ovo cru né Tem muita
proteína tem muita coisa lá que não é
exatamente uma água né não sei o que
você quer dizer com essa
pergunta
Eu também não entendi essa pergunta
Eliseu a regra de que não pode ficar
mais de 6 horas sem dormir também vale
Quando a pessoa está dormindo não
entendi não conseguo
entender tá Eliseu mas nesse caso não é
água né é um alimento o ovo é líquido
porque
mas nesse caso você pode considerar como
sólido
entendeu Bem pessoal tudo bem que a
gente não teve Live semana passada né E
também não
tivemos Live aí Alguns dias de janeiro
então tô meio que compensando hoje né
porque nós estamos já com quase 1 hora
de transmissão eu poderia ficar
tranquilamente duas horas com vocês mas
eu do meu entendimento que ninguém vai
assistir o vídeo depois né quando fica
muito
longo
a de
urinar não ô Eliseu isso é durante o dia
não é durante a noite não que eu tava
falando tá durante a noite é diferente é
só durante o
dia não não precisa ser necessariamente
no mesmo horário não se bem que na
prática vai ser porque você vai tomar
tipo duas vezes ao dia e Então você vai
juntar os suplementos mas não é
obrigatório que junte
não não não é não é interessante você
tomar muito líquido junto com a refeição
porque você vai diluir os sucos
gástricos e vai atrapalhar a digestão
mas o ovo não entra nisso tá o ovo não é
água ele é então não vai ter esse efeito
de
diluir
você pode fazer enema em casa enema de
café enema de chá tem vários enemas que
pode fazer em casa que não vão ser tão
intensos quanto fazer hidrocol terapia
mas vão ter efeito
semelhante o coentro ele tem silício na
composição Então ele pode sim ajudar a
eliminar toxinas que tão há muito tempo
no organismo é possível que ele tenha
esse efeito sim
não eh cristais na urina não é a mesma
coisa ter
cristais eh na verdade vai ter cristais
na urina mas necessariamente vai ter
pedra no
zins o magnésio ele sim ele faz parte de
receptores hormonais esteroides
inclusive da vitamina D Então não é que
ele vai ele vai ajudar sim a melhorar a
sensibilidade do receptor a vitamina
D
essa pergunta não é relevante Eliseu
porque a questão dos hormônios não é o
quanto que ele é poderoso ou não é
quanto que você tá com ele equilibrado
ou não essa esse poder da é porque o
cortisol e os hormônios tiroidianos
geralmente eles são mais importantes que
os hormônios sexuais mas não quer dizer
que eh eh você vai poder ficar de boa
com o cortisol equilibrado e o Ti
equilibrado e os sexuais desequilibrados
Então tem que ter equilíbrio de todos os
hormônios porque o sistema imune dessas
pessoas é mais eficiente tá do que das
outras que desenvolve sintomas como
qualquer outra
doença é parte dos nutrientes do ovo se
você cozinhar o ovo demais ou fritar
demais vai
perder porém aesb idade desse ovo cru
vai ser um pouco menor do que o ovo
cozido então tem vantagens e
desvantagens aí não vai ter mais
proteína mas vai est as proteínas vão
estar menos degradadas mas o problema
principal não é nem proteína é alguns
outros nutrientes como
astina luteína que tem no
ovo sim e dmso é possível ser encontrado
de baixas concentrações em
plantas sim cicatriza mais
rápido não não significa cristalis deoc
salato e cálcio não
significa necessariamente pedra nos vins
não tem gente que tem Cristal e não tem
pedra elizu isso aqui eu não vou poder
te responder isso é um caso específico
do seu irmão e ter que purar um
ortopedista aí para verificar isso tá
isso não é uma pergunta adequada para
responder aqui na na
Live bem pessoal vou encerrar por aqui
estamos com uma hora de transmissão só
vou esconder essa última do Eliseu
aqui o aloa não tem a mesma ação do
prasol desbloqueador de pró em geral ele
vai ajudar
na na proteção da
membrana ele vai ajudar na proteção do
epitélio do intestino e do estômago
então ele vai formar uma camada
protetora agora ele não vai bloquear a
produção de
Ráo como é o caso dos
prazois tá então el não bloqueio a
produção de ácido como é o caso dos
prazois ele vai e fazer uma camada
protetora
ok
Adriana não posso fazer isso
infelizmente tá isso aí já é um trabalho
de consultório não de de esse que nós
fazemos aqui no
YouTube Sim compai é muito bom sim
concordo com
você então Obrigado a todos vocês uma
excelente noite e até a semana que
vem